now last night I explained the Democrats
so obsessed with beating Trump in
November are working overtime to keep
Americans even children miserable now
case in point next door to Washington DC
the Fairfax County Public Schools have
announced that children will not be
permitted to return to school five days
a week as normal only providing a two
day a week or an all online option
parents and students are rightly
outraged New York City has announced
it's going to adopt a similar plan for
the Fall leaving all the working parents
there in a complete bind and kids of
course are left wondering if life will
ever be the same for them again now
adding parent stress and confusion
Governor Cuomo said today that he may
not let schools reopen at all now
Democrats the teachers unions are
putting their own political interests
first and education secretary Betsy
DeVos must have watched the show last
night
because she nailed him on it today there
are some creating false paradigms for
the fall and here right in our
neighborhood the DC area Fairfax County
which is one of the most well funded I
would call it an elite public school
system in America offered families a so
called choice for this fall either 0
days in school for their students or two
days it would fail America's students
and it would fail taxpayers guess what
vengo vengo gets results after we
highlighted the fairfax county disaster
the district announced later this
afternoon that it is considering
mandating just three feet of social
distancing between the kids meaning that
more kids could potentially go to school
in person ok well it's a step in the
right direction but it's still far from
what the science is telling us we know
that mortality rate in under 25 from the
CDC data is less than 0.1% we have no
evidence
that there is significant mortality and
children without coexisting diseases but
again Jill Biden's party of science
ignores scientific fats and data that
show that shutdowns haven't and do not
work and instead they opt for strafing
America with fear and panic in hopes
that it's going to hurt the economy and
thus hurt Donald Trump on election day
now of course they don't give a damn
that in the process our children and our
families will be collateral damage a lot
of our kids are hurting out there
they're struggling with loneliness with
social isolation the American Academy of
Pediatrics spoke about that a very
forceful statement from pediatricians
across the country that said we got to
get our kids back into school if
lockdown Joe wins however you can expect
that the Fairfax in New York school plan
to become the norm for the rest of the
country parents already totally stressed
out by economic uncertainty are gonna be
pushed to the edge I've heard from them
it's a house of cards and it gets worse
Biden supporting ed you crass are eager
to work less but also indoctrinate more
now what am I talking about
well black lives matter zealots now have
outsized influence in school districts
like Fairfax County and their goal is to
turn your kids into hardcore activists
by remaking education from top to bottom
now you don't believe me well here's
video our next guest shot from a public
work session of Fairfax school leaders
we have great stuff going on with our
social studies curriculum and we want to
talk about all the other things in the
components that really will create the
anti-racist school system we have to
look at it systemically we have created
the chief equity officer position
and we've done some good work in this
but we're a long ways away from it is to
be a meaningful challenge to systemic
racism I believe we must be honest about
our policies and our interactions
honesty I love how they're just reading
everything by the way if the teachers or
educators couldn't they just speak well
when you watch that you imagine the
worst of Howard Zinn plus maybe the
16:19 project and you get the picture
now every subject every extracurricular
activity will be perverted to turn your
kids into mini Elon omar's they're gonna
learn that capitalism is racist history
is conventionally taught is racist
literature most of that's racist
patriotic songs racist and the
Declaration and the Constitution of
course they're racist are you sensing a
theme here well say goodbye to the 3 R's
reading writing arithmetic and say hello
to the three C's of critical race Theory
cancel culture and community organizing
and what about teachers or
administrators what about those people
who don't really agree with this and
either tacitly or explicitly resist well
they're gonna be driven out maybe
they'll be found guilty in newly-formed
race tribunals which some students want
in colleges now when you think you're
too busy and I understand to get active
in your local school board's decision
making think about losing your child to
this sort of whacked-out thinking that
parents and alumni have allowed to
dominate college campuses by the way to
the U you want so has a mixed-race kid I
hope you realize that doesn't
automatically make you anti-racist
in fact you're doing the opposite you're
first of all objectifying and pesticides
in someone like me I hope you have
exercise in it is a whitewash to
blackness
you're saying that's okay oh that's
trendy well I'm not your friend she's
talking about people I guess who have
mixed-race children that they're not not
racist in fact they're more racist now
you shouldn't want the people who taught
that young woman within 10 feet of your
child's classroom or even lecturing them
online for that matter
so the dholtze in fairfax county
applauded themselves though for ramming
through a name change of their school
their high school total pandering
meanwhile they closed their classrooms
three days a week hurting the minority
kids they supposedly care so much about
the motion before us is to proceed with
the name change from robert e lee high
school that is unanimous the motion
carries
i am tasked as superintendent to bring
to you my recommendations great possible
new name for lee high school the first
is john lewis the next name is Barack
Obama the next name I have to share with
the board is these are Chavez I just
want to share with you my seasonal shop
a stuffed animal doll that I've had
right here okay that doll has more brain
power than the grown woman holding it
and she's close in any way to making
decisions about our kids education our
schools under the guise of racial
awareness will be pressured to these
types of radicals pressured to bow to
them people who would rather sit at home
and conduct online propaganda sessions
then act like the essential workers that
they are where they're in actual
classrooms interacting with actual kids
teaching them actual essentials in
person and of course these will be
precisely the types of people you can
expect to populate a Joe Biden
Department of Education because Biden
he'll always cater to his leftist Union
base this is
be a teacher Orion Department of
Education and it's not gonna come from
the top down it's come from the teachers
up you know I have a partner the White
House oh my god that's scary is this
what American parents really want a
president who will preside over the
total erosion of our schools a total
abdication to teachers unions whose
first loyalty isn't to students but to
their own membership and ultimately of
course the Democrat Party we can make a
different choice
let's support a president as Secretary
of Education who are out there fighting
for parents and kids let's take back
control of our schools and use them to
train children who love this country and
understand its history its economy and
its political system let's win this
election and teach the left the most
important lesson of all that this
country belongs to all the people not to
a small number of anti-american radicals
now if we choose that we won't fail our
kids will win for the future and win for
the country and that's the angle